what's up everybody it's your boy muffin
back at it again for Oh Jonah TV
bringing you this time fails of the week
and also joining me today is Ryu dou
stay what's up man hey what's up I'm
happy to be here man
ready to see some fails of the week as
you put it yeah I mean like it's it's a
fun series and even if you don't play
Tekken all the time it's gonna be a
laugh let's let's get into it
[Music]
all right so our first clip here
submitted by sir mate cool we got a good
combo going Oh downstairs this is a
learning opportunity for the people at
home if your heads towards you know
somebody who's standing your hitboxes
like down that your feet but man that
sucks that sucks so bad
this one's coming to you from Roy FZ we
got a rage oh yeah you can duck it but
you could do that too I guess like gosh
right from Easter Quito Easter Oh armor
I like it barri okay
starting off simple for the throw yep
got a good mid option another throw
alright it's tough to break oh it's
tough to break that's the one takeaway
[Music]
Ferhat
the the bear sends us this these are
amazing names by the way big props by
the way like I love watching these and I
love when the person who got dunked
submitted it where they were just like
yeah I admit from Ellie and Ozzy oh the
big flips and how sweet I like it come
on come on Brian
what's going on tell me about it you
playing that play for real
it's they're both for deep Oh Brian come
back there has to be the fail of the
week right when you come back from DJ
hero himself let's do it
promotion chance to antigen oh my gosh
Oh No that demotion from skinny penis
from Ascalon ooh let's see Steve mirror
Ascalon so headbutt come on sub what's
her couch
I swear someone's looking for it a
single button throwed he's so confident
coming at you from trusty hate Oh
science step hop kick avoids the useless
hot pick in the game sense of awareness
too though the situation was gonna go
whack I keep wide but throw the pizza
like even exactly what my absolute doggy
self would have done in education
Robert Daniel bring you some Safina ooh
I like it I like it
okay you treated with reeds drive from
nine mountain the King starting with him
on the ground
ah no no no no no no no this goes I
can't believe there's more there's more
there's literally born
the fun fantasy syndrome right there how
do we defeat God oh we throw our human
weapon at God eventually dies no big
deal from ultra instinct potato the high
level plays peri-peri a baby striker who
would Eddie made just like me not
looking great though it's fine no
recovery I hope so okay got a counter
hit launch but nothing we're just
chillin we're chillin still he's okay he
lets it happen he lets that second dick
just go right here like a crazy boy come
on stop discontinued already okay from
Tommy
starting off getting strangled I like it
just flip up in there scar exten I'm not
sure which one he is or they are but oh
okay from Lars Jun fan plane neither of
those characters see it 10 backflips in
the row oh we got we got flips both ways
I've seen this movie before
from caravan streaming from azula's Nina
the back boots uh-huh sure but it's cool
it's cool it's cool Kings all had it
coming six minutes that we add a video
so get your king clips of you winning
and I'll be back on here for next it's
been the movement joining me again was
we you know it's been a lot of fun show
me a side of Tekken that I don't get to
see very often from the tournament
circuit side of things and it's been a
damn enjoyable yeah dude like absolutely
and you can find more about where we say
words about fighting games down in the
description you can check out more Osho
2 videos all around this video I'm
assuming and yeah well you know we're
gonna be back we're gonna do some other
stuff here for the channel and if you
liked it Annalise no but these be
staying too you know stick
don't touch the the YouTube dial we'll
be back